hello and welcome to see your playing
phys I haven't played them before still
surprising how many new opponents you
get that you never have played before
yeah trying to convey the expres the
impression that I actually know what I'm
doing which is not the case and maybe I
should have played a 5 myself okay let's
get rid of one of the pawns at least
yeah bishop on ji tun actually one idea
of that setup is that this Bishop can
quite often become quite strong which
doesn't really and look like it's going
to happen now I try for Nigeria 5am to
get some negativity going to perform my
pms but i think i can go Bishop a three
that's not so terrible okay so probably
getting this Bishop some point
okay now no I bishop is not so bad okay
Bishop to e3 simple chess
hey you can play and that's in the solid
way what to do maybe see form
establishing in our post on d5 for the
bishop even Bishop g5 take you on f6 and
putting something on d5 it's not such a
bad idea Black is very sound and solid
shouldn't have any any kind of problem
let's say okay so okay I'm cover this
I'm covering this for the mode hmm okay
I can also play very aggressively like
g45 and then put something on d5 okay
let's try that just a blitz game
whatever
even rookie one book t1 is interesting
check if it if he takes twice on c4 than
g5 bowel do you really think I just
blundered that I had some idea that
looks pretty dangerous for black I was
thinking maybe I'm wrong it's it's
certainly possible okay now I k98 es
route 27 group c 7 this is probably true
okay
hooked 793 mmm you can just hmm how do I
have something in this position
hmm has probably nothing I looked 793 is
threatening made this is the problem I
cannot take on 27 down and fe Bishop g5
is also okay for him
it's equally sure he is ok going for
Bishop t5 i'll try to here to try to
exploit that rook position still being a
little bit of bishops there maybe maybe
not a good decision but we'll see after
93 the drawing tendencies of the
opposite colored blush bishops should be
very high
I can never take on g6 because of the
ship t5 check currently I'm not
threatening that's because hunk g4 is
check ok now get this in taking this
wait I can also check with the bishop
look there check check check it's not
okay i want the porn that I guess that
must be must be more ambitious and I
have to have to keep my keep the pawn
let's go up to your phone then look
everyone Wow okay everyone he goes back
okay I need the H pawn here age 52 age
60 g one that could be a winning idea
non-threatening look g one King f8 age
six still threatening this
hmm i think that loses I'll just take
Giselle now rucca changing stinks I've
got rope she ate at the intima I think
that should win don't see how I defends
it yeah maybe you can give the bishop
still
Luke g6 is a move also for objects d6 is
called Bishop c5 I mean okay I can mean
I can try that let them find that move
first and then see I've worked through
to c6e as well oh look esox check rookie
6 check
and shooting for some lukien time
warning okay that's what should it
should be enough and we win the peace
check please that's what I'm thinking
okay um nothing better here I don't
think swim oh it's real good for this is
a better to be avoided check check check
everything is rather nicely covered
check check check mate hmm yeah I think
you that g45 idea was interesting but it
shouldn't have gotten that many
dividends check suji 594 and then g6 I
think he must be able to defend that
better but I felt that my I'm not
running much risk because um he
basically has to take only 3 and
something like that i think that happen
also i know we took that first I think I
ok can do that but here he can defend
better for sure
computer gives this for example this and
this I'm not getting in Bishop t5 now I
think that's very draw actually
something this is sure the computer line
yeah that should be sub opposite colored
bishop sending it's a draw and here I
mean it so should be a draw maybe but
yeah it is tricky now this is this is
this is uncomfortable the pawn there on
f7 is is dangerous and he I don't know
he he played all those moves there on
the queenside and I have what I'm doing
there on the King side is more dangerous
he's already lost him the key idea was
that if he is playing a non-move here
some from nothing and I got okay Ruby 7
but can also not do this because of age
6 check it wins German ta cannot prevent
the promotion with the winning end game
been being a piece up mmm interesting
interesting but cash I shouldn't have
won this ending with some more precise
defense so that should have been so
dangerous ok well thanks for watching